ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ทตี้สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
นักเรียนก็มาเจอกับครูว่าตีและครูบี
เอกันในช่องคลอง friend สโมทัยอีกแล้วนะ
ครับถ้า 5
น้องอาร์ตี้คะวันนี้วันอะไรคะฮะโอ้โห
เกือบลืมอ้าวันนี้พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์ครับ
วันนี้วันจันทร์เดี๋ยวนะปากกาปากกาอยู่
นี่ครับ 5 วันจันทร์ว่าวันจันทร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่ 4 แล้วครับ 5 วัน
ที่ 4 เดือนที่ 4 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
นี้เดือนเมษายน
เดือนเมษายน
ครับพ.ศ.เท่าไหร่แล้วเนี่ยมีผช
พ.ต.ต.นะใช่ไหมพอพ.ศ 2500
45 ครับ 5 ปีนี้ 6 ห้าราคานะครับปีคศ
เท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2000  22 ครับปีนี้
ครู Arty เดือนนี้จะเอาเวลาก่อนตอนนี้กี่
โมงคะขอนี่หรอตอนนี้ 8:20 นครับ
20:20 นนะคะนาทีค่ะยี่สิบยี่สิบเลยนะ
ครับขายี่สิบยี่สิบเลขดี
แฮปปี้แมวเอ่อกลับไปที่วันด้วยนะกล้ากลับ
มาที่วันใช่ไหมหน้าวันจันทร์วันนี้วัน
จันทร์เดือนนี้เดือนที่ 4 ใช่ไหมคะได้
ครับเดือนที่ 4 เดือนเมษายนหาอากาศเริ่ม
ร้อนแล้วไหมคะนายอากาศร้อนแล้วครับตอนนี้
อากาศร้อนอากาศร้อนแล้ว
วันนี้เอาเมื่อวันที่ 4 วันที่ 5  6  7  8
9  10  11
โอ้ว
12  13  14 เป็นวันอะไรคะเนี่ย
13 แล้วก็ 14 ใช่ไหมครับหาถ้า 12  13  14
เป็นวันก็เป็นวันสงกรานต์ครับของประเทศ
ไทยนะของไทยเป็นวันสงกรานต์สงกรานต์วัน
นี้ครู Arty ก็เลยใส่เสื้อ
ครับใส่เสื้อลายดอกไม้มีดอกไม้ดอกไม้อ่ะ
คนไทยเรียกเสื้อลายดอก
อะไรดอกอ่ะแฟนสั้นๆน่ะเสื้อลายดอก
ยาวเสื้อลายดอกไม้
เสื้อสงกรานต์
เรียกเสื้อสงกรานต์ก็ได้รายการได้ครับ
คนไทยเราใส่เสื้อ
ที่มีลายดอกไม้แล้วก็สีแบบคนแท็กสีสดอ่ะ
ค่ะอ่านะครับสีสดนามิหลายๆสีสีแดงสี
เหลืองสีเขียวสีสดใจครับได้เป๋ดูแล้วอ้าว
สวยอ่ะคนเราไม่กินนะคะเราคิด
นักเรียนบอกว่าเสื้อที่กู Arty ใส่นะต้อง
ไปฮาวายมอ
ไปเอาออกพอดีคิดว่าเสื้อสงกรานต์กับเสื้อ
ฮาวายก็คล้ายๆกันมีดอกไม้เหมือนกันมีดอก
ท้ายเหมือนกันชายและเสื้อที่กู Arty ใส่
เนี่ยคอเสื้อเนี่ยเราบอกว่าขออะไรนะคอ
ฮาวายใช่ไหมเอาแบบนี้เป็นฮาวายมั้ยใช่ใช่
ใช่ครับเธอเอาอะไม่รู้เรียกคอ cawaii  ray
ขอขอขอขอขอโอเค
เฮ้ยถ้าวายอะไรเวลากูเองเด็กๆไม่เข้าใจนะ
คะทำไมเรียกคาวายนะคะก็เป็นผมคิดว่าเป็น
คอปกเขียวเฉยๆก็มีปกเพื่อ
ปกตายอะไรคอร์ดหวั่นไหวด้วยเมื่อวานเสื้อ
คู่อะตีนะคะนักเรียนเป็นเสื้อสงกรานต์
ใช่ครับพร้อมที่จะไปเล่นสงกรานต์แล้วแต่
ยังไม่ใช่วันนี้นะวันนี้ยังไม่ถึงวันนี้
วันที่ 4 ไม่ใช่วันนี้แต่เราทำวีดีโอก่อน
ก็เลยให้นักเรียนดูหนัง
อันนี้นะคะสำหรับสงกรานต์นะคะเย้
สงกรานต์เนี้ยใช่มั้ยฮะสงกรานต์แล้วก็คือ
จะเป็นอยู่ในเดือนที่ 4 ตอนอากาศร้อนๆนะ
คะร้อนๆเวลาคิดถึงสงกรานต์น่ะคิดว่าครูอะ
ตีกับกูอ่ะถ้าคิดไม่เหมือนกันนะอ้าอร่อย
ครับคู่เอกครับคิดอะไรครับซักต้องพูดถึง
สงกรานต์คู่เอกคิดถึงอะไรอ๋อเพราะว่าคู๋
ต้องคิดถึงโอ๋เอ๊ปีนี้
ใครเออ Series  f ใคร
สักคู่อะที่น่าจะทำหน้างงแล้วเป้อารักษ์
อ่ะครูเอ๋ใช่บอกว่าคิดไว้เหมือนกันเพราะ
ว่าครู Arty เป็นผู้ชายหนึ่งเป็นผู้ชาย
กูเอกเป็นผู้หญิงกูอ่ะพี่เป็นผู้ชายก็จะ
คิดไม่เหมือนกันละแล้วก็ 2 ครู Arty เป็น
อายุเป็นน้องเอ๋เนาะอ้าๆครับ
14 ปีไหม
กูอัดที่อายุที่กลัวตีอายุ 45
45  45 เป็นน้องครูเอส 24  15 แล้วหรอคะ
เอกจบละ 4
เป็นน้องเป็นน้องนิดเดียวหรอเป็นน้องไม่
เยอะใช่ไหม
ถ้า 45 ก็ 9 ปีอ๋อ
ครูเอ๋อายุมากกว่าครู Arty  9 ปีก็
ว้าวเป็นพี่ครับเป็นพี่จะซูมทำให้หน้า
เด็กนะคะขอบคุณค่ะครู
กูอีกพยายามทำหน้าจริงนะคะแบบ 0 เนี่ยทำ
ให้หน้าเด็กนะ
เวลาที่สองอย่างนี้ค่ะนักเรียนอายุที่
ห่างกันนะคะก็ความคิดก็จะต่างกันจะไม่
เหมือนกันก็จะไม่เหมือนกันนะคะที่บอกว่า
ไม่เหมือนกันคือครูพี่เขา XO เอกคิดอะไร
ฝั่งกรานชาวเอกก็คิดวัด
ก็วัด
ถ้าใคร
ใครก็คือว่าปีนี้
นางสงกรานต์คือใครอะเนี้ยโอ้โหจะเขียน
ราคะแต่ก่อนที่จะมาฟังเรื่องของครูเอ๋
อยากรู้กู Arty คิดอะไรคะสงกรานต์อ๋อ
สงกรานต์ถ้าถ้ามีวันสงกรานต์ครัวนี่ก็คิด
คิดว่าจะไปเล่นน้ำสงกรานต์ที่ไหน
น้ำสงกรานต์ที่ไหนมิมีน้ำใช่มั้ยมีน้ำที่
น่าใจเหงา
แต่ต้องน้ำหอมๆนะคะครับใส่ดอกไม้ลงไปใส่
ดอกไม้เราไปในน้ำแล้วก็กินเล่นจะเป็นเล่น
ที่ไหนไปเล่นที่ไหนดี
พ่ายไปดอกไม้แล้วใส่อันนี้เลยกว่าติอ๋อ
อ๋อนี่วันนี้เป็นน้ำอบน้ำอบก็จะมีกลิ่นมี
กลิ่มหอม
หอมนะคะหน้าดีหรือว่ายน้ำทำให้น้ำหอม
คอมหอมๆไปวางไว้ก่อนนะคะเวทเตรียมน้ำหอม
เฮ็ดเตรียมจะเป็นเล่นน้ำสงกรานต์แล้วจะนะ
มีมีน้ำอบแล้ว
อันนี้เอาไว้มีพระที่บ้านมีพระพุทธไม่ได้
เล่นสงกรานต์
มีพระเล็กๆครับเราเรียกพระพุทธรูปนะคะ
พุทธรูปครูอธิบายให้กูอื่นได้ไหมพระ
พุทธรูปด้วยไหมครับ
ผู้เห็นแน่ใจนะไอ้กลัวตีวาดรูปพระพุทธรูป
โอเคเพราะผู้จะรู้ดูจะดูกูอ่ะตีว่าสวยไหม
สรุปก่อนนั่งอยู่อ่ะ
นั่งอยู่ KR แล้วก็มีพระพุทธรูปเป็นองค์
เล็กๆใช่ไหมกวนที่ว่าสวยกว่ากูเองนะคะ
โอเคมั๊ยอันนี้ดูรู้แล้วใช่ไหมครับอ้า
เป็นพระพุทธรูปเราก็ว่ายใช่ไหมครับ
มีจีวรได้ใช่ไหมครับอ่านี่องค์กรด้วย 5
ค่ะก็มีพระพุทธรูปใช่ไหมคะน้ำอบไทยบางที
เราก็ส่งน้ำพระเราบอกว่าไปส่งน้ำพระเนี้ย
อ๋อ
แต่ว่าแต่ว่ากู Arty วันหยุดให้หยุดนาม
ได้หยุดยาว 3 วัน 12  13  14 หยุดไม่ต้อง
ทำงานไม่เข้าทำงานโคโยตี้จริงๆกูอาทิตย์
จะหยุดกี่วันค่ะกลัวตี้ก็หยุดอ่ะก็หยุดตา
เดี๋ยวนะอ่ากลับไปที่ปฏิทินนี่มีมีมีมีมี
ๆวันนี้หยุด
13 หยุด 14 หยุดอ่ะคนที่คิดว่ากลัวนี่ก็
จะหยุดวันนี้เพิ่มอีกวันนึงหยุดวันนี้
ด้วยน๊า 55 หยุดที่ 67 ราคา 16  17  16
เป็นวันเสาร์วันเสาร์ค่อยหยุด 57
และวันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์ก็หยุด
สาวทั้งหมดกี่วันเนี่ยเฮ้ยหยุดหยุดทั้ง
หมด 1  2  3  4  5  6 วันครับ 6 วันเลย
สายให้แต่บางคนนะหยุดตั้งแต่วันที่ 9 ใช่
ไหม
วันที่ 9 หยุดอยู่แล้ววันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
แล้วก็วันจันทร์วันจันทร์ก็หยุดเพิ่ม
จำเป็น 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  9 วัน
วันใช่ครับผมบางคนก็หยุด 9 วันบางคนก็
เสร็จวันเลยไปไปไปเชียงใหม่ 3 วันโอเคไป
ไปไปเที่ยวนะไม่มีหลายคนก็ไปไปเที่ยวเรา
ไปเที่ยวอาจจะไปเชียงใหม่ไปภูเก็ตไป
ญี่ปุ่นนั้นอะไรซึ้งโปแต่ปีนี้อาจจะไม่
ได้ไปไกลที่อยู่บ้านน่าอยู่ในประเทศไทย
ได้แล้วอยู่บ้านก็ไปไปวัดนะคะไปวัดแทนนะ
คะอาทิตย์ก็หยุด 6 วันเนาะอายุ 6 วัน
หยุด 6 วันนี้จะไปเที่ยวไหมคะอายุทุกวัน
ก็ไปเที่ยวครับไปเที่ยวด้วยครับปกติแล้ว
วันสงกรานต์คนไทยส่วนใหญ่หรือขวด E เนี่ย
ก็จะกลับบ้านกลับบ้านที่ต่างจังหวัดล้อ
เพราะตอนนี้ก็กลับที่ไหนนะสุด 5 ประจวบ
ครับ
ประจวบใช่ตอนนี้ควรที่อยู่นนทบุรีพอมีวัน
หยุดคนที่คุณจะกลับบ้านที่ต่างจังหวัด
ได้ไงครูเอก็ธรรมดาก็กลับบ้านต่างจังหวัด
แต่ว่าปีนี้อาจจะไม่ได้กลับแม่บอกอยู่
มา
แม่บอกหยุดหยุดยังหน้าเองก็เห็น 3 เดือน
ทำไมทำไมยังไม่ให้ไปทำไมคุณแม่บอกไม่ต้อง
มายังไม่ต้องมาทำไมอ่ะโอมไอคอนขอ
[เพลง]
เหมือนกันค่ะนางสงกรานต์จะมีทั้งหมด
77 หมอมีเจ็บคนหรอ
S7 บทองดีไม่ใช่คนน่ะอ้าวหรอนางสงกรานต์
ไม่ใช่คนเหรอครับขอทรายสงกรานต์ให้สิคน
เป็นอยู่อยู่สวรรค์อยู่ข้างบนอยู่บนโต๊ะ
หวานป่ะทุกปีไม่เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนกันไม่
เหมือนค่ะครู Arty แชร์ส่วนจะอนุญาตครู
เอ๋แชร์จะกินได้ไหมคะปัญญาอนุญาตแล้วครับ
ขอคุณแม่ก็เลยถามว่าปีนี้นางสงกรานต์เป็น
ใครใช่ไหมว่าไม่เหมือนกัน
นี่กว่าที่เห็นไหมเห็นหรอครับเดี๋ยวนะนี้
เป็นรูปตัวที่เห็นช้าง
ใช่
ควรที่เห็นผู้หญิงสงกรานต์อยู่ไหน
ไม่เห็นผู้หญิงไหมอ๋อมีผู้หญิงคนนึงนอน
อยู่บนที่นอนอยู่บนช้างใช่ไหมมายชายอ่ะ
คุยเอาสีแดงแล้วกันปากกาสีแดง
อ่ะนี่ค่ะมีช้างใช่ไหมคะ
รักๆนางสงกรานต์
นางสงกรานต์นอนอยู่บนช้างสบายสบายเนาะ
ทำไมนอนล่ะครับทำไมนอน
เอกไม่รู้คิดว่าสบายๆขอโอเค
ที่คือครูเอ๋นะเปิดเว็บไซต์เราก็อ่านนะคะ
เพราะว่าถ้ากูเองโทรศัพท์หาคุณแม่คุณแม่
ก็จะถามทันทีว่าเอ๋ปีเนี้ยนางสงกรานต์
ชื่ออะไรแล้วก็อ่ะ
คุณแม่ใช้ภาษาชาวบ้านมีอะไรอ๋ออะไรขี่ทาง
ใช่ไหมปีนี้ใช่ถ้าเป็นภาษาที่ 2 ของความ
เชื่อจริงๆเขาจะเรียกทรงช้างออกขอตรงค้าง
เป็นพระศาสน์เก่าภาษาลาวโบราณใช่มั้ยส่ง
ครับก็คืออยู่บนช้างนั่งช้างมาจะได้ไม่
ได้นั่งนอนเลยค่ะอ้านอนมานี่ไม่ได้นั่ง
ใช่ครับแล้วก็กูอะตี้เห็นไหมคะเหมือนของ
มัน
ลืมบอกเลยว่ากู Arty รู้ไหมคะนางสงกรานต์
ปีนี้ชื่ออะไรอ่ะชื่ออะไรครับก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ชิมให้รู้เหมือนกันนะผู้่ก็เดี๋ยวนะ
เดี๋ยวถามเหมือนกัน
จิรินีเทวีอ๋ออ๋อกิริณีเทวีออกไปอ๋อมี
เทวีอยู่ข้างหลังชื่อแปลว่าไม่ใช่คนเป็น
เทวีแบบนี้ไหมเป็นก็คือนักเรียนคะอันนี้
ขวดที่เห็นไหมเห็นครับเห็นครับคณะครูเอ๋
คุณครู Arty รหัสเราอยู่ที่โลก 5 อยู่บน
โลกนะเป็นคนธรรมดาเราเป็นคนธรรมดาอยู่บน
โลก
แล้วก็ก็อันนี้ข้างบนใช่ไม่มีเมฆก็
คู่เอกขอว่าเป็นเทวดาแบบฝรั่งน้องๆถ้า
เทวดาเทวดาเนี่ยเป็นผู้ชายค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็น
เทวีนี้เป็นผู้หญิงเงิน
แต่ที่กูอีกว่านี่เป็นเทวดาของนักเรียน
น่ะออกจน a ไม่ใช่ของคนไทยใช่ไหมโอเค
เทวดาไทยไม่มีเสื้อ
หาไม่มีเสื้อเนี่ยไม่มีเพราะว่าร้อน
ประเทศไทยร้อนไม่มีเสื้อ KR ให้นักเรียน
เข้าใจเทวดาก่อนเนี่ยนะว่าเทวดาไทย
สวรรค์ใช่มั้ยอยู่บนสวรรค์
การได้แต่ถ้านางสงกรานต์กิริณีเทวีก็อยู่
บนสวรรค์เหมือนกันเป็นเทวดาเป็นนางเป็น
เทวีเป็นเทวีมันเหมือนนางฟ้าเนาะโอเคอ่า
เป็นนางฟ้าเทวดาผู้หญิงชฎาผู้หญิงเรียก
นางฟ้าเทวดาผู้ชายเรียกเทวดาอ่าใช่หมอมี
เคยละอายอันนี้เทวดาไทย
ในทางเห็นไหมครับเห็นแล้วครับ
เทวดาไทยอ่ะแต่ว่าอ่ะนางกิริณีเทวีน่ะนะ
คะอ่า
จัดทำงานกับหัวหน้าเทวดา
ชื่อพระอินทร์นะคะก็นะคะเราจะเอามาปีนี้
เนี่ยเวลาออกพ่อแม่เนี่ยก็ของเอ๋แล้วก็
อยากจะรู้แค่ว่าเออชื่ออะไร
ปีหน้าปีนี้มายังไงก็อ่อนอนมาแล้วก็ถือ
อะไรอ๋ออ๋อถืออะไรครับปีนี้ขอตัวนี้มื้อ
นี้ถือปืนอ๋อว้าวถือเปลื่นถือปืนแล้วอีก
ข้างนึงอีกข้างหนึ่งถืออะไรครับถือ
ตะขอเป็นคดีขอมั้ยตะขอ
เหมือนตะขอที่ขี่ช้างใช่ไหมเวลาคนขี่นั้น
ก็จะต้องมีตะขออันนี้ด้วย
อ่าก็จะสับไปที่ช้างนะช้างมายช้างไปให้
ช้างเดินไปได้ไหมครับอ่ะแต่ครูเอกก็ไม่
รู้นะว่าถือปืนกับถือตะขอมีมินนิ่งอะไรมี
ความหมายอะไรไม่รู้มาดูแล้วน่ากลัวนิด
หน่อยเนาะใช่ครับผมคิดว่าถ้ามีปืนก็จะ
ต้องมีเรื่องเรื่องไม่ดีมีเรื่องไม่ดี
เท่าไหร่ถ้ามีปืนนะครับๆ
น่ารักอ้อมก็ไม่รู้ก็ไม่ได้บอกแต่ว่าเขา
บอกอย่างอื่นคือปีเนี้ยนะฮะอะ kv ชื่อ
กิริณีเทวีแล้วก็นั่งช้างมาแล้วก็ช้างรับ
สารก็ดูแข็งแรงเนาะทั้งแรงดีนะคัดแต่กู
Arty รู้มั้ยใครเป็นคน
ประกาศอันนี้ไม่ใช่ใช่ๆๆๆประกาศณวันที่ก็
กำลังกำลังคิดว่าจะถามใครเป็นแล้วใครเป็น
คนบอกว่าปีนี้นางสงกรานต์ชื่ออะไรปีนี้
ใครเป็นนางสงกรานต์เพราะมีนางสงกรานต์ 7
คนใช่ไหมบอกมี 7 คนแล้วปีนี้ใครเป็นคน
ใครที่จะเป็นนางสงกรานต์ใครเป็นคนบอกเขา
บอกว่าอันนี้ต้องมีประกาศจาก
ประเทศไทยนะคะไม่ใช่กินเองนะต้องรีบ
ประกาศเลยนะอ่าก็กูแอบไปดูในดูข่าวดู
เว็บไซต์ก็บอกว่าปีนี้ประกาศดีนะนาง
สงกรานต์ชื่อนี้มีค่ะทีมนี้อ่ะคุยเอาแค่
รูปมาให้ดูนะคะคนที่ประกาศใช่ไหมคนที่รู้
คนที่รู้ว่านางสงกรานต์ชื่ออะไรคือคนนี้
เลยใช่ไหมคนนี้เป็นใครครับอาจจะไม่ใช่คน
นี้แต่เป็นคนอาชีพนี้อ๋อ
โอเคคิดนี้คุณครูเข้าเป็นทีมค่ะไม่ใช่คน
เดียวไม่ใช่คนเดียวตายแต่คนอาชีพนี้เนี่ย
เราเรียกว่าออกโขน Prime หอ
พราหมณ์หนึ่งคูณด้วยเป็นอ่ะเป็นโหรด้วย
เป็นพราหมณ์ด้วยนะคะอับไม่ใช่พราหมณ์เฉยๆ
แต่ต้องเป็นโหรพราหมณ์
นะฮะกูอะตี้รู้จักโหรผ่านมั้ยรู้จักครับ
รู้จักครับผลพราหมณ์ก็คือคนที่เอ่อรู้
เรื่องทำพิธีเกี่ยวกับเรื่องของครามไงค่ะ
หัวหน้าพิธีการ
คือเป็นคนที่รู้อนาคตอ่ะใช่ไหมลูกอนาคต
รู้เกี่ยวกับพิธีพราหมณ์นะคะคือพราหมณ์
เนี่ยมีพิธีพราหมณ์อาจเป็นประเทศไทยมี
พราหมณ์ฮินดูพุทธพุทธศาสนาพุทธไหว้พระสวด
พราหมณ์ฮินดูแล้วก็จะมีพราหมณ์อันนี้เป็น
พราหมณ์นะคะคนนี้เป็นหัวหน้าพราหมณ์หาคน
นี้ก็เป็นพราหมณ์นะคะแล้วครามไม่ใช่คน
เดียวครามเขาจะมีเยอะมากกว่าตี้เขาก็จะมี
ได้ก็จะมีไม่ใช่คนเดียวเป็นคนบอกว่าจะมี
ทุกคนมาแล้วก็ดูกันชนะเซ็กส์ปีนี้ใครชนะ
ใครใครเป็นนางสงกรานต์เหมือนแป๊บนักเรียน
ก็อาจจะไม่ใช่สองคนนี้นะคะเขาเป็นทีมค่ะ
ไม่ใช่ทำงาน 2 คนจะเป็นทีมรู้เองไม่รู้
ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ว่าพราหมณ์ท่านไหนเป็นคนบอก
อะไรข่าวไม่ได้บอกแต่ว่าเป็นทีมของ
พราหมณ์ใครครับ
ครีมของพราหมณ์จะบอกว่าเนี่ยที่กิริ
กิริณีเทวีนะ
ใต้
แล้วพราหมณ์ก็บอกอีกค่ะกูอะตี้บอกว่าอะไร
อีกครับนี่ค่ะ
อะไรเอ่ยน้าอันนี้เป็นพญานาคใช่ไหมครับ
เนี่ยใครขยันอ่ะยาหน้า
ต้องรู้ว่าใครเป็นนางสงกรานต์แล้วก็ต้อง
รู้ว่าหน้ากี่ตัวหนอทำไมถึงต้องรู้ว่า
หน้ากี่ตัวมีนาคมาด้วยเหรอครับแต่ถ้าอยู่
พราหมณ์เขาจะดูแล้วรู้ว่าปีนี้มีหน้ากี่
ตัวหรือหมอพราหมณ์ก็รู้แล้วความก็บอกอีก
แล้วใช่ไหมครับว่ามีหน้ากี่ตัว
แล้วปีนี้ปีนี้พร่ำบอกนะครับว่ามีหน้ากี่
ตัวครับถามบอกค่ะถ้าบอกว่ามีหน้าคุยให้
ครบ 4 ยังเนี่ยหาครบแล้วมีกี่ตัวอ้าๆ
เสียนะคะอื้ม
โอเคน่ะมีนาด 4 ตัวแล้วนะคะอ่าปล้ำบอกกับ
กูอะตี้ทำจะบอกว่าปีนี้มีนาคทั้งหมด 4
ตัว
หน้า 4 ตัวนี้มาทำอะไรครับมีหน้าสี่ตัว
นี้มาทำอะไรให้น้ำอ๋ออ๋อ
นาคมีน้ำออกมาจากปะหน้านี้กวนตีเห็นมี
หน้าคนน้ำออกมามีหน้าคนนะสี่ตัวค่ะ
ถ้ามีนาดให้นางน้ำใช่มั้ยมีน้ำเยอะไหมมี
น้ำเยอะไหม 4 ตัวกูอาตี้คิดว่านาค 4 ตัว
ทำผมจะตกมากๆหรือนิดหน่อยอ๋อ
เดี๋ยวนะกลัวตีไม่รู้ว่าพออ่าปี้อื่น
เนี่ยที่ไม่ใช่ปีเนี้ยนาคมีกี่ตัวและตัว
ที่คิดว่าถ้าสี่ตัวก็น่าจะประมาณปานกลาง
ไหมปานกลางไม่มากนะไม่นอนจะมีน่าจะมีทั้ง
หมด
1-4
ครับปีกมีมากที่สุดท้องแค่ 4 ใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะอ๋อ
ถ้ามี 4 ตัวก็แปลว่ามากที่สุดแล้วก็ถ้า
งั้นกวนพี่ก็คิดว่าน้ำน้ำต้องเยอะมากแน่ๆ
ฝนอาจจะตกเยอะมากก็แม่นาค 4 ตัวถ้าแก
อ้าวไม่ใช่เหรอครับ
เอาก็มีหน้าสี่ตัวน้ำก็ต้องเยอะสิทำไมไม่
ใช่เหรอทำไมเออ
กูกู Arty หน้าสีตัวเนี่ยฝนตกนิดหน่อย
อะครับเอ่อครับแต่ถ้าหน้านะ 1 ตัวนะฝนตก
มากๆอันนี้ประเทศไทย
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าอะไรก็พ่อนาคหลายตัวให้
น้ำนิดเดียว
คือครอบไม่รู้เขาบอกหน้า 4 ตัวนะนะฝนจะตก
น้อยแต่ถ้าหน้านาค 1 ตัวฝนจะตกมากๆน้ำ
ท่วมเลยกว่าตีนอ๋อถ้านาคน้อยฝนเยอะถ้านาด
เยอะฝนนอน
เหมือนอันนี้ไงครู Arty เวลาไปโอลิมปิค
อ่ะก็ทำมวยไทยอ่ะมวยไทยเราได้ Champion
ไหมอ๋ออ๋อไม่ไทยเราได้ Champion ครับอ่ะ
ยกน้ำหนักปากเราได้ Champion ไว้ยกน้ำ
หนักเราควรพี่คิดว่าน่าจะได้น้อยนะยกน้ำ
หนักได้ผู้หญิงไอๆเหรอเปี้ยนมันจะให้เขา
ก็เป็นคนเดียวคนเดียวขอ
และฟุตบอลไทยไปโอลิมปิกมั้ยอ๋อเพราะว่า
ฟุตบอลไทยคนเยอะเหรอคนเยอะที่หมอ
เขาเขาโจ๊กนะคะขอโทษนะคะพูดเล่น
พูดเล่นจริงเกิดมีคนพูดเล่นสนุกๆคืนนาค
เนี่ย 4 ตัวเนี่ยหน้าก็ตัวที่หนึ่งก็คิด
อ่ะหน้าจวนโอนให้น้ำแล้วนั่นฉันให้ตรงนี้
แล้วกันคือนาคแบ่งกันให้น้ำก็น้ำ God มัน
อาคิตะคิดว่าเพื่อนให้น้ำแล้วก็ไม่ให้แต่
ถ้านาค 1 ตัวหน้าไข้น้ำแล้วนะให้น้ำให้
นางเอกก็มีให้หรือยังให้น้ำอีกก็ทักจำไม่
ได้ว่าให้น้ำที่ไหน
ก็เลยให้เยอะเลยแล้วมีตัวเดียวให้เยอะเลย
อ้อ
อันนี้คือคนคนแก่พูดให้ฟังนะคะนักเรียน
ครูเอกก็ไม่รู้ว่าครามจะหมายถึงอะไรแต่
ว่าคนแก่คนแถวบ้านต่างจังหวัดคู๋เขาก็จะ
บอกว่าอ๋อนั่งเยอะๆหน้าก็เธอคิดว่าเพื่อน
ให้น้ำแล้วก็เลยไม่ได้ให้น้ำพนาจตัวเดียว
ก็คิดว่าอ้อยังไม่ได้ให้น้ำก็เลยให้น้ำ
เยอะๆก็เขาเป็นความเชื่อแบบนี้นะคะก็เลย
ปีนี้ก็เลยน้ำน้อยสิครับปีนี้ก็น้ำน้อย
ว่ามีหน้าสี่ตัวใช่ไหมเขาบอกน้ำจะน้อยปีพ
เอาแก้วน้ำมากใช่ไหมคะ
ปีนี้น้ำจะน้อยลงจริงไม่จริงไม่ทราบกู
Arty รอรอเดือนที่สิบเนาะว่าฝนตกมากๆไหม
ลืมไปแล้วครับขวดตีก็ลืมไปแล้วก็ถึงเดือน
เอกก็ลืมเหมือนกันนักเรียนคะแต่ว่าคนต่าง
จังหวัดแถวบ้านครูเอ๋น่ะจำนะโอ้วันนี้ปี
นี้ฝนจะตกน้อยเขานาค 4 ตัวจะเป็น topic
ที่เขาจะคุยกันแล้วคุยกันเรื่อยๆจนกว่าฝน
จะตกสหรัฐคือตั้งแต่เด็กๆครูเอ๋จะได้ยิน
คนแก่พูดแบบนี้นางสงกรานต์แล้วยังมีนาง
สงกรานต์กินอะไรด้วยบางทีแล้วแต่ปีแต่ปี
นี้แค่นอนมาก็ไม่ต้องกิน
ปีนี้ก็สบายเลยค่ะนอนมามาไม่เหนื่อย
ปืนมาด้วยสิเนื้อเพลงมาด้วยนะคะก็อันนี้
ถ้านักเรียนมีเพื่อนคนไทยแล้วก็ไปบ้าน
เพื่อนต่างจังหวัดแล้วได้ยินคน
คนแก่ๆเนาะห้ามรุ่นครูเอ๋เอ๋รุ่น 60  70
80 คุยกันนักเรียนจะได้เข้าใจอ๋อผู้หญิง
ที่อยู่บนช้างเป็นนางสงกรานต์ชื่ออะไรใช่
ไหมครับที่ไหนๆไม่คิดว่ารุ่นครูปาร์ตี้นะ
ไม่สนใจ
ไม่รู้แล้วไม่สนใจแล้วนางสงกรานต์นาง
สงกรานต์เป็นใครสนใจว่าได้หยุดกี่วันน่ะ
ได้ไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ได้เล่นน้ำได้เล่นน้ำหรือเปล่า
ใช่ครับกูเอกก็ต้องเตรียมคุยกับแม่นาง
สงกรานต์
แม่ชอบถามนะคะ 1 นางสงกรานต์
โอเคเนาะมันหนีครับอ่าวันนี้ก็ได้รู้
เรื่องของวันสงกรานต์เพิ่มขึ้นอีกนิดนึง
นะครับเพิ่มขึ้นเพราะปกติปกติไม่เคยรู้
ว่าไอ้นี่นางสงกรานต์ด้วยหรอเฮ้อทรายราคา
ละลายสงกรานต์เราไม่ได้คิดเองกับพราหมณ์
เขาจะมีอะโขนพราหมณ์ก็คือจะโคนก็คืออ่ะคน
ที่เรียนแล้วก็รู้ใช่ไหมคะรู้อนาคตรู้
เหมือนกับค่าดูครู Arty ก็จะบอก Oh โอ้
Arty ปีหน้าจะรวยมากนะเสียงก็
โขนเรียกว่าโหนะคะ
แต่ไม่ใช่หมอดูธรรมดานะโหรต้องเรียนเรียน
มากๆแล้วก็ต้องอาจมีพิธีมากๆหนคราวหน้า
กัน
โอเคเนาะหมดเวลาแล้วอ่าโอเควันนี้เราหมด
เวลาแล้วครับแล้วจะไปสงกรานต์กันแล้วใช่
ไหมคะเดี๋ยวอาทิตย์หน้าครับอาทิตย์หน้าไป
สงกรานต์ค่ะได้ครับ
โอเคถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่
ครับในวีดีโอถัดไปเดี๋ยวยังมีวีดีโอของ
ครัวตี้กับครูพี่เอกกันอีกอยู่นักเรียนรอ
ติดตามกันนะครับในช่องคอม When  Store
ไทยนี้สำหรับวันนี้ถ้าใครชอบคลิปนี้นะทำ
ยังไงครับพี่เอ๋กดไลค์กดไลค์ตะไคร้กดให้
ครับด้วยนะครับมาแล้วเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอ
กันใหม่ในคราวหน้าครับวันนี้ผมครัวตี้
แล้วกูเห็นต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับสวัสดีครับ
พี่เก๋โทรไปทำให้โรงเรียนได้มา